welcome to this video will ass off from
Sweden Queens gambit what kind of
variation let's see a classical one who
should be so I'm going to play my normal
line and everybody and their dog play
this line now not be disowned yeah it's
good it's a good line I've played this
um myself quite quite a number of times
with plaque some years ago even nowadays
itself very much on vogue okay so going
to keep this pawn chain
yeah white enjoy some pretty substantial
space advantage here but black hopes to
ultimately get his Bishop traded on a
six so we're going to see what happens
yep has to he has to play again this
kind of move because c6 might be might
be a problem okay so here I cannot do
any tactics am with with the capture and
b5 and so on I just have to play the
normal moves see what happens something
very similar happened in known a recent
game aren't with white against nakamura
where anand won a pretty nice game at
the end Nakamura had had an opportunity
early on in the game that he did not
take and after he passed this chance he
got into trouble one issue was the King
side there was this kind of play going
on and I just dashed this out quickly
not quite sure if it is really the move
to to play or not but look at it looks
kind of okay gaining some space is
weakening there we could weakening
himself a little bit I thought a big
deal that but anyway yeah blacks plan is
mostly defensive he is not really
intending to do something something
great in terms of forward plate he's
mostly trying to mostly trying to to
equalize and
stay stay solid no I mean this is not a
huge huge deal maybe but I have I
definitely have the a file hooray
interesting i can go h5 why not I might
have g5 and it's not that great but
maybe 95 is a move if he takes I can
take with the deep hole and allow 94 94
in connection with Queen a 6 an invasion
looks pretty nice yep i'm going to take
with this part of course this is this is
the ultimate square 1 d4 for this night
okay so Queen eight so how do you defend
this
takes tanks
text a group is 69 piedra p6 oopsie
eight rupees several methods now be
seven last night you know that's that's
not on this earth is there a better move
in somehow okay let's let's start with
that Luke is six rupee aid is also very
nice he has he has almost no move but
okay
yeah and then to see it Ruby 7 is not
threatening anything unfortunately it's
a very hard time to use anything here f5
yes then King up worse than 97 hitting
no not really i can also just take with
a night maybe 97 immediately but it's
kind of hard to believe i can take c6
with them
alright thats that should be really
really good in this position
94 and we'll attack f5 and b5 and this
night only 7 has no way to defend that I
don't see that happening night f8 94-96
i take c 6 and promotes so
that's the way that's the win it's got
no way out of that I can take one and c6
check black humming reside oops I know
church yep yeah that we had we had to
this is very comparable to the Anand
Nakamura game sits the it's at least the
same piece distribution with the lights
and kind of typical with with Russia
playing with a night's yeah wyd is
definitely a little a little bit better
just a little bit I don't like age six
very much it's a move that you're very
often want to go g6 stabilizing and age
6 I don't know okay I want this night
has to go there here here anyway because
it's doing nothing on c3 it either can
go here later I'm not blundering a one
or go to here or here after f4d point
have recaptured only five so this is why
this is good and now I'm piling up here
getting the FL maybe he should have
tried to be quicker on the FR with Queen
c7 for example it's not so easy to play
this position it looks it looks simple
but here already black as in serious
issues and the computer is agreeing plus
0.8 as I'm climbing yeah here we're
talking our at one point something
already 95 yeah it said that's
disastrous after that white is winning
yes I probably probably had something
better even look a success what the comp
is giving but I don't think that this
pod anything
here yeah okay this is the alternative
of course which is also also very nice I
have an interesting plan here here again
not blundering 295 but let's just put
this on the board like here here and now
black black has no moves this is kind of
frustrating likes this this and now rook
e8 he has actually rookie 6 funny but
black is in zouk this one yeah black
isn't soup smile that's really cute him
Black has no move if he goes here I'm
going here and after this check this is
hitting so that was even better what I
played but this is I mean it's also
pretty pretty terrible from like yeah
and we know that was a pretty clean game
I'm satisfied with that yeah he has to
probably somewhere around here it's me
starting with this age 6 smooth
somewhere around here black has to be a
little bit little bit more precise to
trying to avoid this infiltration on the
AFL it was awkward when I when I got
there okay well thanks for watching